this right hailing Gap has become a
Lifeline for Iranians who've lost their
jobs Arash masumi is one of them but a
steep decline in the value of the
national currency during the last two
years has led to record high inflation
he had the closest shop in the small in
Tehran four months ago after the rent
doubled and his sales dropped
my main source of income now is from
online taxi my wife works too but still
we can't make ends meet we used to live
in good areas of Tehran but with time we
had to move to cheaper places I had a
good life before I never looked at Price
tags but today we think twice while
buying cheap Goods Aura says the small
used to be crowded and the shops
employed more staff he says he wants to
move to Canada like many of his friends
I'm not looking for luxury I just want
to live a normal life if it's here a
futile we delisted or reduced numerous
Foods in our lives such as dairy certain
fruits and meat eating Outsiders no
longer an option these days
after Iran's economy was damaged by the
pandemic and sanctions caused by former
president Donald Trump's withdrawing the
U.S from the 2015 nuclear deal with
Tehran and world powers annual inflation
reached about 50 percent according to
National statistics the price of food
has increased by 80 percent in a year
placing Iran among the first five
countries with the highest food
inflation rate in the world crippling
U.S sanctions are seen as the major
driver in the sharp rise
the national currency has lost 50
percent of its value since the
government led by President Ibrahim race
he took office in August 2021 racy says
tackling inflation is a priority but
many accuse the government of
downplaying economic realities
the real has lost 29 of its value since
Nationwide protests following the death
of 22 year old Masa amini in police
custody last September poor economic
growth and Rising unemployment have also
led to social unrest
you lost
the
planning scenario planning for your
business for your life and I think this
is the most important reason for
immigration of irania right now
suffering from a loss of purchasing
power members of Middle East class
appear to be victims of inflation in
Iran and that could lead to some of them
looking to leave the country and taking
their Capital with them cnmco solo Al
Jazeera Tehran